[Music]
it smells good in here our own cooking
confidence coach nanny bubby is back in
studio thanks to chapman automotive the
sponsors of this delicious segment today
we are learning how to make homemade
ricotta cheese
how do you like that so the first thing
is uh-oh it's coming to a rolling boil
i'm going to tell you what it is right
after i put three tablespoons of white
wine vinegar in there okay moving it off
the heat okay we're going to say hey
siri set the timer for one minute and
we'll get back to it but modern cooking
but what this yes and i'm told everyone
at home's phone starting now there you
go there we go so this has four cups of
milk and two cups of heavy cream okay
now i just want to say this it always
says heavy whipping cream and when i
read recipes that said heavy cream i
went oh i can't find it i can only find
whipping cream it is the same thing okay
all right good to know so we are going
to let this separate it's going to take
a minute and the milk is going to
separate so the curds and the whey
and so that's what the whey is it's the
liquid and you're going to see it in
just a minute i can't believe you're
making cheese right now and what i want
to tell you is you're going to get to
two because this is the thing this is so
easy to make that all if you are a new
cook and you want to impress just make
this as an appetizer
serve pizza and salad
but everyone is still going to think
you're a genius okay
ricotta on my pizza is
my favorite thing so it's gonna
firm up like this and what is this oh
here we go fabric here yeah so did you
get this shot of inside the curds and
whey and let me just show you what
happens i'm going to pour this after a
minute
we're going to pour that right into
cheesecloth that's been dampened yeah
and there you go and it's going to start
draining okay you're going to see in
here and what are these materials the
way this is a cheesecloth okay yeah
yeah of course cheesecloth
what else would it be okay well let it
start draining but see this is the way
okay right as in whey protein got to
stop that watch and this then leaves the
curds which look like this so this is
how it firms up this now is ricotta
cheese i feel like i'm in italy right
here hold this for a second you are in
italy your nanny bubbies italy okay
okay so putting this here okay this is
oh cheese cloth off oh is that something
that always happens yeah always yeah
you got to be careful with your life
does that happen okay so in here
just because i like to season it we're
going to put a little bit of um dill
okay okay okay we're going to put a
little bit of scallions right here yeah
and then we're going to well we're going
to save that till later what is that
chocolate that's um basil for after so
we're just going to mix this up look at
that look how beautiful oh my goodness
oh my god is that gorgeous wow and i and
i normally see just ricotta cheese just
plain but this has some spice and
seasonings in it yeah yeah that's the
key right so now we're going to take
this and just put it onto the platter
now do you see
that what that is going to do is that is
going to extract right that is going to
rest for about 20 to 25 minutes and then
it's going to be all like this it's
going to be ready to literally lay out
onto the platter i wish you guys could
smell this oh i know and i wish you
could eat it too so here's the deal this
is my favorite kitchen tool
cool
done
what they said that's right i'm taking
the honey yes you are and we're just
gonna mix up that i just wanted you to
see that and we're gonna just take this
around oh my goodness right
and you see how simple that was this is
definitely an impressive dish for people
if you're hosting and literally in 25
minutes what we just made three minutes
ago
is ready to go now this is fresh
tomatoes around the fresh
and a slotted spoon so that you don't
get this has got oil and vinegar on it
right and then i like to mix it up so i
roasted these tomatoes before i came
more texture yes more texture i love
that i'm learning i like yes
i don't even think to say that that is
fabulous okay so there we go wow and now
we're going to sprinkle
the basil
onto the tomatoes
we've got 30 seconds i'm going to try
yes you are and then we're going to take
some french sea salt ooh
gotta wipe those that's like the
finishing touches there we go and now
some bruschetta's around it now you can
eat and if i need to read all right this
is delicious check out nanny bubby's
kitchen and garden okay on social media
take it take the rest take the rest and
yeah and say um spread love like butter
online at nannybubby.com you can find
the recipes we also want to thank
chapman automotive always for sponsoring
this segment wow this is delicious jc
awesome to you looks so good thank you
ladies the theater